new york's state attorney general says a
former federal prosecutor and
an employment lawyer will lead an
investigation of governor andrew cuomo
five women accuse him of harassment
including four
who used to work for him many of his
fellow democrats have called for his
resignation
cuomo says he won't step down our
national correspondent jerica duncan is
following the story jerica good morning
good morning to you anthony the attorney
for one of those accuser charlotte
bennett
said that the attorney general's
election really just shows
how serious she is about this
investigation now governor
cuomo denies any inappropriate touching
and has apologized for his actions if
they made the women feel uncomfortable
but at the end of the day he refuses to
step down despite growing calls
for members within his own party to do
so
on monday 21 women in the state assembly
released a statement asking
the attorney general leticia james be
given the appropriate time
to complete her investigation and over
the weekend we learned that cuomo
reached out to
several state leaders and lawmakers
asking them to be patient
and allow an investigation to proceed
and in a turn of events the democratic
top leader in the state senate
andrea stewart cousins said that right
now for the good of the state the
governor must resign
this is a change for her because for
days she said
wait for the investigation anthony the
governor under continuing fire jerika
duncan thanks tarika